known as the venice of the north the
city of bruges is famous for its
numerous canals and medieval
architecture
and just like its italian counterpart
you can explore the city in style by
boat captain mikhail dalla knows his way
around the countless canals of this city
dating back over a thousand years
let's say the first settlers here there
were norwegian people probably vikings
and in that language docking station the
structure you see here it's called
brigia and that's probably where the
name of the city comes from so brigia
back then ships could dock right by the
old market square
the historium located there today is an
interactive exhibition that takes
visitors back in time
the 13th and 14th centuries were
brutal's golden era
well the sea of bruges got so rich in
the middle ages because it was in the
center of western europe
it was in between north and south europe
and all the traders from around the
world came to bruges also bruges was
very important because it did import and
export so it be
it basically became the center of europe
for trade and commerce
in 2000 unesco declared the historic old
town a world heritage site
towering over the market square is the
83 metre high bell tower
the iconic landmark of bruges
just round the corner is another major
tourist attraction the groningen museum
home to a number of paintings by world
famous flemish artists
bruges is also famed for its lace
industry although very little is made by
hand nowadays
back in the 16th century lace was a
status symbol
the city has a number of traditional
bobbin lace-making workshops
if you had money to pay
you you
you you bought it and you showed it that
you had it same for gold and jewelry you
know
yeah of course
no
it's it was the same place
maybe it's coming back one day never
know
and there's no escaping chocolate in
this city
dominic pezzona is perhaps the most
adventurous chocolatier in belgium
among his inventive concoctions
chocolate snuff
and a praline with roasted onion
pizona even boasts a mishla star for his
sweet treats
my nickname is also
because sometimes people think i'm
shocking people but that's not the idea
to really shock people and in the
beginning when i was making for example
chocolate with wasabi it's the japanese
spice a lot of people thought that i was
completely crazy but little by little
get more respected for what we do
bruce has a resident population of 120
000
but nearly 30 times that number come to
visit the historic city every year
rouge is a fantastic place the
architecture's lovely the beer is great
there's lots of chocolate shops i like
the lace shops and the women are
fantastic
it's really like historic and really old
which i'm not used to in the u.s and it
has all these like really modern shops
too mixed in in the downtown area so
that's really cool
we love living here because it's such a
beautiful historic city everything's
closed together and there's a wonderful
park in the center of town
with its historic architecture and
numerous tourist attractions bruges
offers visitors a perfect combination of
the past and present
you